Rainbow six siege has breached its way
into closed alpha so it's time to talk
strategy there are 10 operators
available five attackers and five
defenders each with their own unique
ability knowing how your skills fit into
the team dynamic is going to give you an
edge so you can pull off some sweet
coordinated maneuvers instead like just
dying a whole lot let's start with the
attacking team and the dude you'll
probably pick first sledge who doesn't
want to be a badass with a hammer they
can just bash through stuff willy-nilly
but you never want to be the only one
breaching it's too obvious coordinate
with a teammate or set up your own
breach charge and then swing your hammer
while your enemies are looking at the
explosions and if your teammates have
the enemy distracted sledge can make
some great flanking runs and pop up
where he's least expected twitch is the
opposite of sledge not meant to lead the
charge or flank but rather to support a
team push she has a deployable drone
that's similar to what you use in the
scouting phase ideally your whole team
has parked their Scout drones in good
out-of-the-way places allowing you to
check their camera feed for Intel but if
not twitch has your mid-match scouting
covered her drone can also shock enemies
for 15 points of damage making it good
for downing enemies that are already
damaged by grenades gas or gunfire it
can also disarm traps if you're sharp
enough to spot them or if your enemy is
dull enough to put them out in the open
thermite's up next and what the thermite
do thermite's things it's right there in
the name thermite will blow a hole in
any reinforced wall no problem but it
sure takes its sweet-ass time
enemies can see and hear the fuse
burning so thermite makes a great
distraction while you execute another
breach or flanking move at the very
least avoid rushing in right after your
thermite blows unless you've chucked in
some grenades or are following the
recruit with the riot shield the recruit
is like the sixth man whose unique
ability is the riot shield but the
shield actually replaces his primary
weapon it's good for going through
breach holes provided you're crouching
to protect your legs and for peppering
pistol shots through barricades and
walls enemies firing back at you through
the wall will probably hit the shield
suckers Thatcher is another attacker and
his specialty is meddling with
electronics given that the defenders
have the most annoying and possibly
overpowered piece of kit in the game the
heartbeat sensor Thatcher's EMP grenades
can really help cover your advance while
your team is moving into breech position
and if one of your breach charge fails
to detonate there's probably a jammer
nearby just waiting to be fried by
Thatcher's grenade don't leave any EMP
grenades in your pockets you never know
when a c4 charge or gas trap is going to
be waiting right around the corner the
last attacker is Ashe she rocks the
breach charge launcher which basically
fires barricade busting grenades and is
super badass she can breach with the
speed of sledgehammer but with the
safety of projectile distance so you
sort of confuse the enemy with
simultaneous breaches support a push
with a quick follow-up reach or just
mess with the defenders mines by
breaching surfaces you aren't actually
near and have no intention of going
through psychological warfare is a must
in siege psyching out defenders can
encourage them to make mistakes mistakes
that you can capitalize on so how do you
avoid making mistakes on defense
coordinate your barricade placement with
your team designate one player to shoot
drones during the scouting phase consult
your security cameras when the attackers
are on the move and don't just freak out
when all the breaches start coming
because they're gonna come you can help
delay the breaching and throttle the
scouting by using mute the defender with
the jammer place these juiced-up
wireless routers behind walls to block
remote breaches and run to a choke point
during the scouting phase to block the
drone parade the range is pretty short
on these guys though so place them
carefully and when the action shifts
from the place your jamming to the place
you're not jamming just pick that little
bad boy up and take it with you if mute
blocks gadgets smoke blocks people with
remote detonated gas bombs smoke can
turn a hallway into a death trap or at
least do some sweet area denial setting
these traps near entryways can stop the
enemy short burning precious seconds off
the clock and bringing your victory ever
closer toss one to where the enemy is
grouping up to scatter them or Chuck one
into a recently breached hole to make
them think twice about coming in slowing
the attackers advance is
great defensive tactic and the strong
barricades that castle can place do just
that
it takes an enemy three melee hits to
break down a normal barricade castles
barriers force the enemy to burn time
actually breaching and if mute puts a
jammer behind one then the breach charge
they spend all that time unfolding was
all for naught
castles barriers offer cover from enemy
fire as opposed to the mere concealment
offered by normal barricades cover
protects you from bullets concealment
does not learn the difference give
yourself a defensive edge by placing a
deployable shield down next to the wall
you want to shoot through and if you put
it near the door that's totally blocked
up castle has got that area locked down
if or rather when you happen to catch a
bullet or two you'll be glad to have
look on your team
rooks deployable bag of armor will
either fortify you from the start or
patch you up mid match a downed player
gets revived at half health but if
there's armor waiting you'll have a full
strength fighter back in no time
if you deploy the armor bag early then
rook is free to go off on flanking
maneuvers without depriving his allies
of the benefits of his unique skill just
remember that if you go outside have a
plan to get back inside quickly or
prepare to deal with the aggression
coming your way when the game
automatically points you out to your
enemies and finally the last defender is
the guy who looks like a jerk and uses
the jerkiest gadget around pulse his
heart rate monitor is awesome to use and
so aggravating to plan around so be sure
to stay alive and keep it in play as
long as possible
sniffing out enemies and calling out
their position is a great way to give
your team an advantage and if you find
the right angles to shoot them through
floors or ceilings well that's a great
move just be sure you know the map well
enough not to expose yourself while
you've got your eyes glued to the screen
play to the strengths of each character
and communicate with your teammates and
you'll be on your way to saving or
protecting an innocent life just kidding
no-one saves the hostage share your own
tips in the comments below and happy
hunting